Disney is desperately seeking Aladdin
Kim Kardashian does not play when it
comes to drug accusations plus another
emotional night on America's Got Talent
I swear Simon Cowell gets a paycheck
every time someone cries watching this
show hello friends we are halfway
through the week and I'm happy to give
you guys a break from any Jay Z news or
Robin China because we have got to talk
about what's going on with Disney's live
action
Aladdin now these live-action
adaptations of the Disney Classics have
been hugely popular and for the most
part I'm glad enjoy them but do not ruin
Aladdin for me I have such a strong
connection to this movie the music Robin
Williams I'm going to say it seeing a
little brown boy down and out in his
life become the hero it's like a magic
carpet ride now there have been no
casting announcements maybe yet though
in April it was reported that Will Smith
will appear as the genie take a look at
what Guy Ritchie who will direct the
remake said about that casting rumor I
have to tell you I love it if that's the
case and everything I understand that
seems to be going swimmingly
he's certainly my number one choice and
I bet we'll come together okay Will
Smith I can't say I can't say yes
because you know how these things are
so will is guys first choice but the
jury is still out not only that but
producers are reportedly having trouble
finding their Aladdin should we be
nervous I don't know that's why I've got
to bring in my girl and fellow Disney
geek ash cross Missouri I'm here for the
blow new colour Perry don't you dare
close your eyes no listen okay so the
Hollywood Reporter is reporting that the
casting process for Aladdin has gone on
for months but so far they're unable to
find the guy yeah apparently there have
been a number of rounds of screen tests
and thr says director Guy Ritchie has
even gone back to review early taped
auditions my current boyfriend's death
fatale and resume were reportedly
considered to play Aladdin but the role
is most likely going to go to an unknown
actor which I am down for especially if
they go as a big star like Will Smith
alright so Disney says they are looking
for a twenty-something actors
can sing and dance and is a Middle
Eastern or Indian descent since I only
checked off two of those boxes I say
they traveled to the other side of the
continent and find him I think there are
plenty of Bollywood stars who are
perfect for the way and exactly I mean
you've got a Kobe as if they're blaming
a lack of talent out there I mean I want
to get the studio the benefit of the
doubt maybe they've just seen so much
talent that it's hard to choose that's
just my positivity personally I'm going
to root for fan favorite Victoria Starr
Avan Jogia he looks just like Prince
Holly and we know he can sing a dance
from his time on Victorious and the
internet wants him well they better
figure it out quick because apparently
it's holding up casting Jasmine who you
guys think should play aloud and let us
know in the comments section and by the
way ash this weekend will be done at d23
the Disney convention in Anaheim so
hopefully we'll get some more answers
about a lot of it follow me for all
those updates thanks girls for joining
us all right clearly we have a lot of
thoughts on this but we are moving on to
Kim Kardashian now in a series of
snapchats teasing her and hubby Kanye
West's children's fashion line followers
were quick to call out what appear to
look like white powder on a table behind
her many claimed it was cocaine and Kim
did not take kindly to these accusations
and quickly responded with this tweet I
do not play with rumors like this so I'm
going to shut it down real quick that's
sugar from our candy mess from Dylan's
candy shop clearly can't have no time
for rumors for the best part about this
it wasn't even sugar not to really put
this thing to bed kids to snapchat once
again to explain my candy boat please
stop no no that's mine so we did go to
Dylan's candy shop I did think that it
was our Pixy Stix but after all that
this table in the background is a marble
table you guys like come on I thought it
was Mike so come on I don't play like
that
like I come on I've kids it's just not
my lifestyle I've never been like that
and I don't even
it was a Laurel table people I care not
she came to see our instead of
responding to her brother Rob latest
scandal Kim's over here having to
explain what this white streak on her
table is you know we got time for that
which is why I'm moving on I'm going to
talk about America's Got Talent
last night more than 12 million people
tuned in and I'm thinking to have
something to do with the fact that a you
never know what you're going to get and
B it looks like your freakin
heartstrings
case in point 13-year old Angelina
Greene Angelina's dad left her mom when
she was little she told the crowd music
was her escape before she let off those
pipes
[Music]
[Applause]
Oh
[Music]
how is it the ones with the most tragic
stories have the best voices her
performance was so stellar this happened
and I loved it so much that I'm going to
hit the goal
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the show also paid tribute to late
contestant brandon rogers who died in a
car accident on june 11th after he
already filmed his audition to honor the
29 year old singer the show aired his
full audition at his family's request
but you know here's something you didn't
see he team got the judges to dish a
little bit on each other I thought it
was so cute and it is Wednesday so
consider this your hot date tree most
likely to be flirty with a contestant Oh
Heidi Heidi Heidi I'd milk like your
little swagger thing going on Mel and I
you all look very handsome
there's a lot of hot guys on the stage
with their shirts off and which judge is
most likely to take a little too much
time during critique Howie
hydrogen is coming up you can't listen
to me for one time which judge is most
likely to cry during the performance
none of them have no emotion or you can
catch our new interviews with the
America's Got Talent judges and hosts
Tyra Banks tonight on ET and as always
subscribe to e t--'s youtube channel for
more daily Denney and stick with ET
online.com for all the latest in
entertainment it's only Wednesday people
so who knows what could happen
alright bye
[Music]